REGARDING CRITICISM OF BOB
MUELLER AND THE FBI.
THAT'S THE FOCUS OF
TONIGHT'S "ANGLE."
CRITICS OF THE PRESIDENT AND
THIS CHANNEL ARE HOWLING
THAT WE ARE PUTTING THE
COUNTRY IN DANGER.
WHAT'S OUR CRIME?
ACCURATELY REPORTING THE
ALARMING BIAS WITHIN
ESSENTIAL COUNSEL BOB
MUELLER AND HIS TEAM HAVE
UNEARTHED NO EVIDENCE OF
SO-CALLED COLLUSION BETWEEN
TRUMP AND RUSSIA, THE LEFT
CONSIDERS IT BASICALLY IT'S
THE STAFFING AND THE TACTICS
OF THE MUELLER
INVESTIGATION.
IN
AND THEY ARE NOW GOING INTO
FULL ON APPEAR PLEXY.
PATHETIC AND ALSO DANGEROUS
ATTACK.
AND HOW CONSERVATIVE MEDIA
IS FUELING THAT DIVIDE RIGHT
NOW.
>> THEY ARE FOMENTING A
CONSTITUTIONAL CRISIS.
WHAT THEY ARE DOING COULD
LEAD TO VIOLENCE.
>> Laura: OH, REALLY, JOE?
COME ON, EVEN YOU DON'T
BELIEVE THAT LET'S GET THIS
STRAIGHT.
THE DEMOCRAT SMEAR MACHINE
BUT THE SPECIAL COUNSEL IS
BEYOND REPROACH?
THEY HAD THEIR BILLIONAIRES
LIKE TOM STEYER LAUNCHING
THESE ABSURD IMPEACHMENT
EFFORTS ON TV.
THEY HAVE HOLLYWOOD
INFECTING THEIR PROGRAMMING
WITH TEDIOUS ANTI-TRUMP
VITRIOL AND WHO KNOWS HOW
MANY CONGRESSMAN AND
SENATORS ARE NOW DEMANDING
THE PRESIDENT'S RESIGNATION.
YET, THEY WANT US TO TONE IT
COUNSEL?
AND THEY WANT US TO REFRAIN
CURRENT MEMBERS OF THE
MUELLER TEAM?
PEOPLE LIKE JEANNE RHEE AND
THEIR WORLD WARPED VIEW YOU
CAN CALL FOR A PRESIDENT WHO
DECADES OLD ALLEGATIONS BUT
WE CAN'T CALL FOR THE
RESIGNATION OF DEPUTY FBI
DIRECTOR ANDREW MCCABE WHO
IS AT THE HEART OF THIS
ENTIRE MESS?
WELL, ISN'T THAT NIFTY?
IT'S LIKE HEADS, YOU WIN.
TAILS WE LOSE.
NICE TRY.
WE HAVE EVERY RIGHT TO
REPORT ON THE ABUSE OF POWER
WITHIN ANY AGENCY IN
TO FAVOR.
INDEED, IF ANYONE HAS
ATTACKED LAW ENFORCEMENT
UNFAIRLY OVER THE YEARS,
IT'S THE DEMOCRATS AND THEIR
BALTIMORE?
THIS IS THE SAME MEDIA WHO
DENIGRATED LAW ENFORCEMENT
OFFICERS FOR YEARS IN
DEFENSE OF SOCIAL
JUSTIFIABLE WARRIORS AND
FALSE NARRATIVES.
>> WHEN WE EQUIP POLICE WITH
AFFECT ONE SEGMENT OF THE
COMMUNITY, THAT IMPACTS
EVERYBODY.
>> LET'S MAKE THAT CLEAR.
THE CITY IS NOT BURNING
BECAUSE OF PROTESTERS.
GRAY.
>> I DO NOT TRUST.
THIS OH THEY ARE BAD THEY
DID SOMETHING WRONG THEY
DESERVE WHAT THEY HAD COMING
RATIONALE WHICH IS THE SAME
ONE WE HEAR FROM THE CIA AS
WE HEAR FROM POLICE IN THE
CASE LIKE MICHAEL BROWN.
OUR HEARTS ARE OUT THERE
MARCHING WITH THEM.
>> THEY NEVER CHALLENGE THE
LIE OF HANDS UP, DON'T
SHOOT.
AND REMEMBER THEY LAPPED UP
THE FALSE NARRATIVE THAT THE
POLICE KILLED FREDDIE GRAY.
IT WAS ALL A CROCK.
IT WAS ALL DONE TO CAST
ASPERSIONS ON POLICE.
AND EMPATHIZE WITH CERTAIN
MINORITY ACTIVISTS.
LAW ENFORCEMENT DID NOT GET
THE BENEFIT OF THE DOUBT IN
THOSE CASES.
AND OFTENTIMES THAT IS THE
CASE WITH THEM.
SO, NO, I'M NOT DISSUADED
FOR A NANO SECOND BY THEIR
PHONY CLAIMS OF SHOCK AND
DISMAY OVER CONSERVATIVES
WHO HAVE THE TEMERITY TO
CHALLENGE BOB MUELLER, JIM
COMEY, AND ANDREW MCCABE.
AND LET'S NOT FORGET WHAT
THE PRESIDENT SAID LAST WEEK
ABOUT THE RANK AND FILE OF
THAT VERY AGENCY OF THE FBI.
>> WHEN YOU RETURN HOME TO
YOUR LOCAL PRECINCTS, I WANT
YOU TO DELIVER A MESSAGE TO
YOUR FELLOW OFFICERS.
THE PRESIDENT OF THE UNITED
STATES HAS YOUR BACK
100 PERCENT.
>> Laura: DEFINITELY SOUNDS
LIKE HE AND HIS FOLLOWERS
DON'T SUPPORT THE FBI.
LOOK, THE FACT IS, WHAT THE
LEFT IS REALLY UREKD ABOUT,
LET'S BE ON NEST HERE THAT
THE PRESIDENT IS ACTUALLY
FOLLOW THROUGH ON HIS MAJOR
PROMISES.
AND, BY THE WAY, WE SAW THIS
TODAY WITH THE ANNOUNCEMENT
OF OUR NEW AMERICAN SECURITY
STRATEGY.
HENCEFORTH, WE WILL USE A
ADVERSARIES.
WE SEE CHINA NOW FOR WHAT IT
IS.
BUT WE HAVE OUR EYES WIDE
OPEN.
SAME WITH RUSSIA.
IT'S NOT QUITE CHINA.
OUR APPROACH NOW WILL BE
CONSISTENTLY GROUND IN OUR
AMERICA FIRST IDEAL.
IT'S A TOTAL, COMPLETE
REPUDIATION OF OBAMA
ABOUT SO OFTEN FOR HIS EIGHT
YEARS.
SO NO WONDER THE LEFT IS
TOTALLY UNHINGED, SOARING
ECONOMY, TAX REFORM ABOUT TO
PASS, CONFIDENCE HIGH, ISIS
SMASHED, DEPORTATIONS UP,
FOREIGN POLICY REFOCUSED.
BUT AS WE DO SO, WE WILL
CONTINUE TO ASK
UNCOMFORTABLE QUESTIONS AT
TIMES ABOUT BOB MUELLER'S
TEAM OR ANY OTHER PART OF